- We're not prepared for this.
- [man] Incoming!
- [announcer]
T-minus 3, 2, 1.
- Go for ignition.
(button beeping)
(pounding beats)
(rocket taking off)
- [Holdenfield] July 20th, 1969.
- [Neil Armstrong] One small
step for man,
one giant leap for mankind.
- [Holdenfield] In school you
were taught that Apollo 11
lost contact with the
world for two minutes.
(droid falling)
- Not true.
- They found something on that
day.
That they kept hidden for 50 years.
And now, it's too late to stop.
- [female newscaster]
In breaking news.
The governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation
of the entire West Coast.
- [male newscaster]
Moving to higher ground,
it's the only possible
chance of surviving.
- Stay awake my brothers
and sisters, stay awake!
(intense dramatic music)
- This planet has
suffered five extinctions.
This is going to be the sixth.
(people screaming)
(explosion)
- [K.C.] Are we dead?
- No, we are just inside the
moon.
- That might be the greatest
sentence anyone's ever said.
(drone zooming)
(pounding music)
(intense ominous music)